У Білій Церкві, що за 80 кілометрів від столиці,
звичайний робочий день.
За президента України тут проголосували майже так, як у цілому по Україні.
72 відсотки за Зеленського і 24 за Порошенка.
Очікувань місцевих до новообраного президента дуже багато,
і їхнього втілення вони чекають якнайшвидше.
Хай знизить тарифи на газ, підніме пенсії і зарплати.
Хай приймуть закон про імпічмент президента,
про зняття недоторканності з депутатів.
Щоб добре було.
"Добре" - це як?
Ну, як він говорив, щоб так і було.
Щоб краще жилося, щоб  війна припинилася.
Соціологи пояснюють успіх Зеленського тим,
що українці побачили в ньому такого собі Голобородька -
нове обличчя, здатне змінити всю систему.
Разом з тим, зауважують вони,
більшість громадян, вочевидь, не до кінця розуміють,
що повноваження президента в низці питань обмежені.
Приміром, "соціалка", згідно з Конституцією, у повноваження президента не входить,
хоча люди очікують, що саме новообраний глава держави
має підвищити рівень життя та понизити комуналку.
А ви думаєте це президент має робити?
Думаю, так.
Також обіцяні антикорупційні закони  та скасування депутатської недоторканності
майже нереально ухвалити без підтримки парламенту,
якої в Зеленського поки що немає.
Тим не менше виборці очікують, що президент "домовиться".
Справа в тому, що
деякі політичні сили, які говорять:
ми не будемо його підтримувати, вони вже з ним домовились.
Такого буть не може, щоб не було "договорняка".
43-річна мешканка Білої Церкви Аліна вдень працює швачкою,
а ввечері співає в хорі.
Вона, як і новообраний президент України, людина творча.
Захоплюється сценічним образом Володимира Зеленського
і голосувала серцем. Від президента, як і всі у її хорі,
чекає "змін на краще".
Для цього, каже, треба, щоб той змінив міністрів в уряді.
- Але він може поміняти лише секретаря РНБО.
-  Наскільки це можливо і важливо,
міністерство охорони здоров'я можна поміняти.
По-моєму, він в змозі це зробити.
- Не в змозі.
- А хто ж може?
- Верховна Рада.
- Ну, вибачте, я ж тоже не в курсі, я не політик.
Я політикою не цікавлюся, я від неї дуже далека.
Далека від політики, схоже не лише Аліна.
Соціологи кажуть, що більшість українців досі не сприймають Україну
як парламентсько-президентську республіку
і продовжують обирати не просто президента,
а, так би мовити, "царя", який зможе все.
Втім, підігрують їм і самі кандидати, які часто обіцяють неможливе.
Молода родина з Білої Церкви Яна та Едуард, приміром,
сумніваються, чи зможе Зеленський зупинити війну на Донбасі.
Я хотів би, щоб він закінчив війну,
як він і обіцяв, що її закінчить.
Але розуміючи, з ким ми воюємо і хто на нас напав,
це не так все просто. І якщо він думає,
що він якийсь супермен, то він не зробить цього.
Президент як Верховний головнокомандувач Збройний сил України
керує військом.Може самостійно призначати начальника Генштабу.
Як керівник Ради національної безпеки і оборони
він також призначає її секретаря і заступників.
А ось кандидатуру міністра оборони він може лише висунути -
затверджувати має Верховна Рада.
Так само з посадою міністра закордонних справ
та генпрокурора України.
Команда Зеленського каже, що будуть через соцмережі
закликати виборців приходити під стіни парламенту
і в такий спосіб чинити тиск на депутатів.
Ви вийдете, якщо через "Фейсбук" і "Інстаграм" скаже:
підтримайте мене, Верховна Рада не хоче голосувати за антикорупційний закон,
приходьте під Верховну Раду?
Ну, я думаю, да.
Тим часом самі народні обранці на пленарному засіданні у вівторок
озвучили СВОЇ очікування до новообраного президента.
Приміром, у "Народному фронті" вимагають повернути
окуповані території та продовжити курс до НАТО і ЄС.
У "Самопомочі" - прозорого оборонного бюджету,
руйнування схеми "Роттердам+" та скасування недоторканності
з нардепів та самого голови держави.
А у "Радикальній партії" вважають, що президент має переглянути угоду з МВФ
і скасувати рішення уряду про підвищення тарифів.
Як бачимо, очікувань до нового президента дуже багато.
І чим вищі вони, застерігають соціологи,
тим більшим потім буде розчарування.